short Donovan has to hurry he's at
half-court lets it fly
horn sounds Oh half-court bucket yeah
they'll review it but that's going home
for three maybe that kickstart shoot off
of the corner of the game and looked to
me that he got old I would think with
his body type I would kind of look at
him I don't think he's like Doyle and be
nothing good if he plays like a two-yard
you know they're getting the shots they
want they're just not knocking him down
I'll be better than early on in the
first quarter Wow moment
baseline is OB Donovan Mitchell we
talked about his athleticism right here
we've seen plenty of those it just keeps
going up and up it makes my knees hurt
all the rack business hooker
Reggie got pulled away
chuckling but he already did at the back
you can't guard him one-on-one when he's
stronger than you and he's stronger than
both temple and Mac he able to get that
separation and that's all he need but
and they're competing - they're
competing at both ends
[Applause]
ESPN here comes our play in the day
tomorrow
unbelievable batfish shot look at the
explosiveness with the left hand to
right and extends and puts it home this
would be a nine in a dunk contest
Poehler much less in a game look at the
explosiveness of Mitchell lured into the
fourth quarter final seconds winding
down Holliday loses it
anime is a Booker releases it just
behind half-court for Devin Booker
[Applause]
around on the three-point zone Fulton
homes donates $100 to son's charities
buckets for a deep pass against the Jazz
in Dallas ain't go loose ago took it
away from dungeons gets it back puts up
the shot he's in the air one one
thousand two one thousand Booker on the
attack launches this shot as he goes
tumbling over the top of the cameraman
he just knows how to get it off and then
Devon just like and I just got to get a
shot off I'm not gonna loud it on a 7o
run over the last minute change jingles
put that one down young fella well Ricky
Rubio doing a nice job running this play
Joe gets it up getting a double-digit
lead on LeBron and the Lakers
[Music]
[Applause]
all the highlight for show so take it
again give someone else here's another
guy who couldn't make plays Mitchell
splitting the defenders and it goes in
how did it happen
Donovan Mitchell everything his
three-point shooting has been off the
mark the last several games and butcher
lost a handle but somehow manages to get
it dribble between the luego - capela
baiting those fouls wait on the
perimeter
look at that move by seven easy I'm
gonna give it to you but hit it off your
arm
and in your leg Turner who's done a
really nice job off the bench quarters
in Porter with the steal
[Applause]
get it in the area code Donovan's gonna
find it that's incredible
you caught that mr. five surely points
look at aunt Georgeann he will bear
driving to his right and he can go
either way but you know it's like we're
gonna be smart well like who does
anybody try to be dumb
[Applause]
Philadelphia - 23 turnovers leading to
29 points defense right now stifling
Booker off-balance - guys that's you
proud to own the three-point zone go
here in the third shot clock run it down
play the game I didn't expect to see
many plays luckily we got here
[Applause]
kakuzu hooker gets the switch with Mack
Mack [ __ ] hooker raising up
and back to this set but your bets
against Devin Booker not good enough
[Applause]
[Music]
Mitchell Wow business decision made
everybody get out our way about that
athleticism right there big you so long
big active body but this is that tip and
opportunity
Booker pulls from deep high arching
stroke yes
Wow proud to all the three-point zone is
right here no Marcus mark great defense
right right there and book the glut
[Applause]
22 points on a quick seven here in the
third on the other one watch this move
little between the legs and sham and
goes somewhere else
Mitchell pulls up terrain see Jackson
trying to work against Butler the butler
one of the terrific defenders in the
league is he kicks it off the Devin
Booker and Booker with a high arching
rainbow each pass man is denied by OKC
tonight
[Applause]
nice for Mitchell for the 44 time what a
killer shot a little Dancing with the
Stars action mr. Mitchell oh boy
pull up impressive Mitchell jazz 702 run
he would shoot when he first came here
he would kind of turn sideways and now
he's kind of straightened out
Booker we'll look for the four-point
play a Devin Booker just he's really
used his screens well tonight and a
great follow-through
Donovan saves it at midcourt 15 on the
shot clock goes up splits right between
the well and goes around a party forward
yeah
great hustle there defensively by Booker
[Applause]
kicks it out to Crawford sets it fire
[Applause]
defense there but but also just good
recognition head up eyes open the right
guy good rhythm right now nine straight
misses from the three losses but
drives baseline
[Applause]
well under their feet by Mitchell this
is the dunk channel bringing you mr.
Mitchell with the leg spread out I mean
this is like nerf hoops like the stuff
bowler down in the basement you're a kid
you put it on a five-foot hoop but you
go up and you see what you can do
Mitchell's doing it on a 10-foot Oh
unreal Springs so it's passed it to him
here he comes to start the second half
catches the side of the backboard eight
grab the offensive rebound
Booker good look good shot four three
double pumps drives inside once again
closer to the rim and the balls loose
guy
[Applause]
watch this whoops between the legs
gotcha just not gonna get any better
than that ball get over there right now
and if it does
it's got to be a couple things in there
how about Royce Niang the garden to
sixth grade he played on a junior Suns
championship squad in fifth grade is
Booker with a little wry smile and doled
out free agency versus Hornish team
doesn't make the playoffs here's
Jonathan inside
Wilke are able to swing it out to Kelly
Oubre a with a high rg3 round in the
three-point zone Fulton homes donates
$100 to such charities
[Applause]
that's the way to go up a terrible pass
and a wonderful know the first guy that
can knock it down and that's just wit is
what you got it that's a good look
hooker get something and it loads it up
wounded' proud to own the three-point
zone good execution under the timeout
finding the one guy you want to have the
ball he knocks it down
he's got five here and the first 11 and
a half minutes Donovan fresh off the
bench he knew it
peel off in the shot he just put a
rainbow down for three suddenly the
biggest lead Epic's smugglers they shot
up ahead to pucker
slams attack all the right
back foot was there on the baseline
[Applause]
baseline shut down and it goes it
Donovan three to shoot down to to have
to shoot it that is a deep three nothing
but net Donovan
Booker steps in gets the steal
I'm gonna go down but the two-hand slam
defense by for neon Donovan Mitchell the
Quin Snyder said there's really no
guarantee as they beat the shot clock
five seconds put your head down gotta
get something going hooker cashes it in
the Sun desperately trying to bring this
losing streak to one in of a pump so I
got us and gave it away gets it back
four to shoot
down to three I'll have to take that
three deep got it he's on he is just on
sir Institute and that this three puts
him over the twenty point mark for the
21st time this season
I thought Boston was physical with them
the other night that's how you beat this
team but their challenge doesn't matter
is Iguodala got a hand in there and
Brooke are able to raise up and connect
there's Donovan Mitchell who has 26
points gets it away and banks it in what
a shot by Mitchell very creative here
getting this one to go a little push
shot got to let it fly late bender with
the offensive rebound and adding it
hooked up face Booker delivers at the
horn from deep Talking Stick resort
Booker the bullseye Tyler Mitchell
Mitchell knocks down a big time free
Donovan Mitchell the top-scoring
second-year player in the NBA rainbow is
running from deep for the chance but
Spalding has five look at that block
there from Devon book that is HUGE right
there but look at this I mean he ran
into a wall tipped out the rebound by
Ricky his pillar trailer three know if
that ball bounces right to Ricky
[Applause]
[Music]
so there's the heat check by Corbett
right who'd already made four of them
and then look how quickly
Ricki see on the spark triathletes
very difference his hooker taking Oliver
frustration on the rim nine to shoot
put up a left hook himself living races
down the rebound it didn't touch the rim
so they shot the shot clocks at three
down two to a deep three from Donovan it
set shot down a deep nice job right here
Rudy stand with the play getting this
steel right here kicking it over an
extra passes nice boys by Donovan shot
clock winding down down Booker happened
to take a one-leg runner over the top of
Drummond and Helen didn't Drummond just
kind of laughs about that one
after this one here I
the circuit shut he had five rebounds in
25 minutes
that's the beauty of this team both boys
to the basket
[Music]
one thought you had contact whether it's
the change of address or just a role
playing much better in the Clippers Utah
transition Mitchell for three
[Applause]
cuties response afterwards he was able
to have some fun as hooker wanting this
one town play against a lot of great
school not mean great schools obviously
Michael Jordan's obvious but I'm just
talking about guys like George Bell
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content